[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده مع
الاعلام الاسرائيلي وصديقنا الدكتور احمد
فؤاد انور مساء الخير معالي الدكتور اهلا
سيد بيه صديق الغالي ربنا يخلي حضرتك انا
عندي سؤال في البديهيات خالص احنا في
اليوم ال 81 هل ممكن تقول لنا بايجاب شديد
يعني مسار العمليه العسكريه في اليوم ال
81 يعني الجانب الاسرائيلي طبعا قرر ان هو
يقسم قطاع غزه الى ثلاث قطاعات القطاع
الشمالي لا يزال فيه القال موجود لا يزال
فيه خسائر بشريه يوميه في قوات الاحتلال
بتكلم عن جبليا مخيم جبليا بتتكلم عن
مدينه غزه و والشجاع حي الشجاعيه فده امر
بيقولوا ان احنا لقينا انفاق لقينا ار
بيجي لقينا لقينا كان الحديث عن الجنوب
للاولويه ثم الجنوب طبعا بيبقى فيه رفح
مثلا هو الوسط انت قلت الشمال والوسط هو
اجل الوسط اجل الوسط اه فهو حاليا بيتحدث
ان انا بتجه الى الوسط يلا نخلي احياء في
الوسط بناشد الناس طبعا لان هو يعني بيخاف
على الناس فبينزل لهم اعلانات بعض
المنشورات دي نزلت داخل اسرائيل من باب
برض التخبط ان لاقوا ان في منشورات يلا
اخلوا بشكل عاجل وهو اسرائيلي قعد فراض 48
مالوش علاقه اه فبن ضمن الخلل يعني فهو
حاليا في الوسط دير البلح مثلا بيشترك
وعاوز يحاصر طبعا اللاف للنظر ان كان
بيروج ويركز يا استاذ سيد ان الشفا تحت
الشفا هنوصل ودونا فرصه نوصل للشفا
وهنلاقي القاعده بتا بتاعه السنوار
والقياده بتاعه حماس وكل المشاكل اللي
هتحل بس ادونا فرصه ندخل الشفا دخلوا لشفا
طبعا شفنا لقينا ستاره ولقينا جدول لتنظيف
دوره الميه مافيش فضائح دخلنا الشفا طب
دلوقتي قال لك خان يونس في الجنوب احنا بس
نخش خان يونس هي خان يونس اللي في الجنوب
وهي المقض الحقيقي وهي مسقط وصلنا لخان
يونس فين الانجاز فهو دلوقتي هيخش على
الوسط وقاعد يقول في نغمه الانفاق اللي
على محور فيلادلفيا انا هجيلك على محور
فيلادلفيا بس انا لاحظت حاجه انه انا قريت
زي كل الناس انه في عز المعركه الجيش
الاسرائيلي بيسحب قوات
النخبه المتمثله في اللواء جولاني وبعض
القوات الخاصه الخاصه هي التابعه لقوات
المظلات فهل ده له دلاله احنا يعني مش
فاهمينها ولا هو عمليه احلال وتبديل طبيعي
لا احنا احنا وصلنا الى ان بعد ما عائلات
المحتجزين والاسر بيضغطوا دلوقتي عائلات
الجنود اللي في الخدمه بيضغطوا قلك لا
احنا هم بقى لهم كام جوه 60 يوم عايزينهم
ا ا يضغط فبالتالي ب خصوصا جولاني جولاني
يوم 7 سخط 41 واحد 7 اكتوبر دي ده اسمه
لواء جولاني لء جولاني قوات نخبه فالقائد
نفسه اتقتل 41 واحد ماتم وفي خسائر يوميه
في الشجاعيه وغير الشجاعيه فقالوا احنا
عايزينهم فطلعوا فرجعوا رجعوا الاراضي ال
48 ا اتسحب بعد ما اتسحب قوات مظلات ايضا
بريه قوات بريه انسحبت فلقينا كمان ان في
الضربات الجويه ابتدت وتيرتها تقل الراي
العام الاسرائيلي السيد بيقول تحاولوا ما
تخطرش بحياه جنودنا اضرب من الجو عائلات
المحتجزين والقصر يقول لك من الجو هتموت
لي الناس اللي جوه بتوعي فبقى الامر ده
اتحسم ان من منذ ايام قررت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مجلس الحرب ان هو يقلل كمان
الضربات الجويه بحجه مزدوجه واحد ان
القوات البريه موجوده ممكن تصاب عن طريق
الخطا والحاجه الثانيه حياه المختطفين
المحتجزين وليه بتقول حجه ليه مش ممكن
يكون هو ده الحقيقه يعني لا لان انا
تقديري العكس ان ده تمهيد للاستجابه لطلب
حماس باخراج القوات من قطاع غزه وانهاء
الحمله برمتها هو ما يقدرش يقول انا
استجبت الحماس انما يقول انا بستج
للعائلات اصل المحتجزين انا افتكرت فجاه
ان انا ممكن اموت محتجزين بتوعي انا
تفسيري ان ده بيروج ليه داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي انما هو في النهايه بيدخ
للمطلب الاساسي دلوقتي لحماس حماس بتقول
بعد ما انا هطلع اخر جوندي ايه اللي هيحصل
هتضرب اه طبعا هيصب فوني اه فانا لازم
ابقى شريكه في اتخاذ القرار في اليوم
التالي ايه اللي يحصل ده من ضمن اسباب
استرار حماس على انهاء العدوان وانسحاب
القوات و لو ان في سؤال طبعا يعني بيلح عل
حتى يعني ما الذي يضمن لحماس ان هي ان
افرجت عن القوات انه اسرائيل هتلتزم باي
اتفاق بمقتضاه بتقول ان انا لن
اهاجم قطاع غزه مره اخرى يعني لا توجد اي
ضمانات يعني لازم يبقى في ضمانات امريكيه
مصريه قويه جدا وفي الجانب الاخر برض لازم
يحصل على حاجه الجانب الاسرائيلي يقول لك
طب يحي السنوار طب الجزائر يروح الجزائر
اه يعني يبقى اسمله برض ايه نف انت ده
حاجه مطروحه ولا انت بتقول على سبيل
المثال يعني لا انا بقول الاجواء العامه
الاجواء العامه ان انا بطلب كذا وانا بطلب
كذا طب هنتقابل في النص ازاي اه بالطريقه
دي اديني حاجه اديني حاجه اديني حاجه لكن
فكره انه ترحيل او وذهاب يحي السنوار الى
الجزائر دي فكره طرحت اه مطروحه مطروحه من
فتره يعني مطروحه مطروحه اه ا بس طبعا
التراجع اسرائيلي كبير يعني هو في النهايه
بيقول انا بطلب ده ده يدل على ان المنسوب
المطالب بتاعه بينح سر يعني انا لو كنت
بقول راس السنوار ويحيى السنوار وانا هقدر
اوصل له انما دلوقتي بنقول طب يمشي يمشي
طب ده بياخدنا الى الكلام الكتير اللي
بيتقال على محورين المحور الاول
هو ما تسرب عن خطه او مقترح مصري والمقترح
المصري ده مبارك من اطراف مختلفه
والخطه دي اللي قارنا عنها قدمت الى طرفي
النزاع الاساسيين المقاومه وعلى راسها
حماس وطبعا الطرف الاسرائيلي هل ممكن
تدينا فكره بايجاز شديد ما مضمون هذه
الخطه اللي تسربت ولم تعلن بشكل رسمي من
الجانب المصري
يعني كلا الطرفين منهك مش راض يعلن كلا
الطرفين يريد البحث عن مخرج لحفظ ما الوجه
لتقديم شيء للراي العام لديه المجهد
المنهج
فبالتالي الانباء التي تترت من نقلا عن
الجانب المصري من وسائل الاعلام ان في خطه
ثلاثيه الخطه الاولى المرحله الاولى ان في
الافراج عن كل اسر محتجزين على مرحلتين
وتبييض السجون الاسرائيليه واخراج
القيادات الفلسطينيه ا والاولويه ان في
المرحله الاولى اذا كان متبقي نساء ست
مجندات او حاجه اذا كان في
مسنين
اه المرحله بقى الصعبه اللي هي بتاعه
العسكريين دي برض مقدور عليها انما
المشكله في اليوم التالي اللي هو حكومه
تكنوقراط اه تدير قطاع غزه وهناك بعض
الاحاديث ان كمان تدير ضفه فالامر ده اثار
السلطه الفلسطينيه بتقول انا ماحدش تنسخ
معايا يعني انا موجوده لسه فده عامل بعض
الحساسيات انما في نفس الوقت عبر وكاله
الانباء من الجهاد وحماس ان هم رفضوا
الخطه هو الخطه اصلها تمشي اليافطه اللي
فوق دي ممكن نغيرها يعني نفس اللي جوه
وراح انا مغير اليافطه فهو اليفطه بتقول
ايه ازاحه حماس عن السلطه تخلي حماس عن
السلطه انما انا ممكن احط مكانها يافطه
مكتوب عليها حكومه تكنو كرات تتسلم قطاع
غازه وهي طبعا تحت رعايه حماس او برضا من
حماس فهو الفكره ان صدر
تسريبات الجانب الاخر قال ان حماس والجهاد
رفضوا بعد كده قالوا ان الخطه ما لم يتم
رفضها وانا
تفسيري ان احنا بنمه الجانب الاسرائيلي
بيمه الى ان احنا هنكبر حماس انها توافق
على الشرط اللي هي مش موافقه عارف انت
ازاي بعد ما كان البدايه ان انا هقضي على
حماس بقيت انا بتفاوض مع حماس حوالين
المحتجزين عبر وسطاء الحاجه الثانيه ان
انا ضغطت عليها علشان تجيب حكومه تكنوقراط
وانا كده حققت حاجه يعني اكبر اذا ما
افهمه وطبعا من المهم ان انا اقول ان هذه
خطه لم تعلن بشكل رسمي من الجانب البصري
ولكن ما نقلته وسائل اعلام غربيه ووسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه انه الخطه المصريه
باختصار شديد بغض النظر مرحلتين او ثلاثه
الافراج عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين في مقابل
اسرى فلسطينيين واحد المرحله الثانيه او
المحور الثاني في هذه الخطه هو فكره الا
تكون حماس هي الحكومه التي تحكم بشكل
مباشر ولكن لكن يحكم قطع غزه على الاقل
حكومه تكنوقراط يعني فنيين صحيح انا انا
يجي في ذهني انا كسيد اول ماسم خطه زي كده
بما ان حماس سوف تظل كما هي هذا يعني ان
حكومه الترا التكنوقراط سوف تكون واجهه
للقوى الرئيسيه اللي موجوده كما هو الحال
مثلا في لبنان اه لانه بما ان حماس سوف
تظل كما هي وبما ان حماس هي القوه
الرئيسيه يبقى بدل ما يحكم مثلا يحيى
السنوار ولا هنيه ولا غيره هياتي ا رجل
اقتصادي وفني ومهندس وطبيب وهم بيحكموا
نيابه عن حماس والجهاد و كل فصائل
المقاومه ما يقدرش يمس السلاح مثلا يقول
له يلا اديني السلاح بتاع المقاومه وما
يقدرش يكون هو بيحكم بشكل فعلي بدون هذه
الفصائل لان هذه الفصائل هي القوه
الحقيقيه على الارض اقتصاديا وعسكريا
امنيا ممكن يسيب مستشفى مثلا يسيب المعبر
بدون حراسه فبالتالي الحكومه دي تسقط
التكنوقراط اه انما شيء مهم جدا انه ا انت
بتقول كده انه هذا تقديرك ان ده تراجع من
اسرائيل لان بدل ما كانت بتتكلم عن تدمير
حماس والمقاومه الان بتقول انا ممكن اجبر
المقاومه على القبول بالشرط المصري اللي
هي بتسوق على ده تنازل يعني او ان ده ضغط
شديد على المقاومه ان الحكم هيبقى لل
التكنوقراط كانت مش موافقه خليتها توافق
خليتها توافق بينما في حقيقه الامر حكم
التكنوقراط ده معناها حكم الحماس وغيرها
من خلال ا وجهه لطيفه خلال وجهه لطيفه انا
قريت انه اسرائيل قالت ده فيول ستريت
جورنال اسرائيل لم تقبل ولم
ترفض تاكيدا لكلامك يبدو ان هي ممكن تناقش
هذا المقترح اه هي تتمنى دلوقتي انها خلاص
موضوع المحتجزين ده استوى جدا بضاغط جدا
بعد ما قتلوا ثلاثه يوم الجمعه الشهيره 14
ديسمبر من اسراهم وفشلت محاولات الوصول
اليهم اي محتجز يتم اطلاق صراحه من من
خلال
الاستخبارات من خلال القوه بل طبعا
الاعلان المتكرر عن مقتل بعض المحتجزين
والاسرى الصيغه دي مفهومه ان هم ماتوا
بالقصف لان حماس تريد هذه الورقه لتت لن
تقتلهم بالضبط وكان في روايات عديده ان هو
كانوا بيحموه بالمراتب وكانوا بيحاولوا
يطمنو فدي جزئيه ان اسرائيل على استعداد
لتنفيذ عمليه تبادل الاسرى وال مجازين لكن
المشكله الاساسيه هو اليوم التالي يعني هو
التفاصيل حول اليوم التالي ومستقبل قطاع
غزه ومن يدير قطع غزه فحاليا الامور مهيئه
في الجانب الاسرائيلي لاتمام الصفقه لكن
الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل يعني في عندنا
داخل الصحف الاسرائيليه كلام كتير يعني من
ضمن الكلام الكتير انه
ا رئيس
الاركان سابق اه طب قول اتفضل انت ا د
حالوتس هو الوحيد من بين رؤساء اركان
الاسرائيلين اللي جه من القوات الجويه وهو
مشكلته شخصيه هو اولا بيقول حاجات خطيره
جدا بيقول يا جماعه صوره النصر اللي
الوحيده اللي ممكن نطلع بيه من الحرب في
غزه هي صوره الاطاحه بنتنياهو
احنا اتهزمنا خلاص من الحماس ونخش بقى في
اللي ممكن نعمله احنا ممكن نعمله ان احنا
نضغط اكتر ونحتاج اكتر ونعمل اعتصامات
نعمل اضراب عن العمل ا على الصيان مدني
لغايه ما يحصل سقوط لنتنياهو هو ليه بيقول
كده لان هو كان رئيس اركان حرب لبنان
الثانيه 2006 ابقول انتوا عملتوا فينا ليه
كده يعني انا استقلت وبهدلت وتحقيقات
والعدد كان 120 واحد اللي ماتوا اه 120
زائد مجموعه من المدنيين قول 30 ثاني ايه
الارقام اللي احنا بنشوفها دي ايه الخساير
ايه الاعداد دي في ظل الفصيل ده كان حزب
الله معه كوريا الشماليه ومعاهم سوريا
وبيجي لهم و عندهم مطار وعندهم ايه ايه
انتوا ازاي تعملوا في انا كده وتسيبوا
الراجل ده فهو بيقود حمله لدرجه ان قالوا
له طب بالنسبه ل انقلاب بالقوه يعني شايف
التوقيت الزمني المناسب يكون ايه قال لهم
سؤال عن انقلاب يعني انقلاب عسكري فهو
بيوضح بقى ايه عشان ما يبقاش في لبس ققول
اه الانقلابات العسكريه اه انا ضدها من
حيث المبدا يعني فهو طبعا فض ما يقدرش
يقول انا هعمل الانقلاب بكره طبعا ما فيش
حد بيقول قابلوني بكره فهو حاليا دان
حالوتس احد الوجوه الرافضه لنتنياهو
والمنادي بان هو يقال اثناء الحرب منهم
موشي وجي علون ده كان وزير دفاع ايضا
ومجموعه اخرى من القيادات العسكريه اللي
منهم جيو ايلاند اللي كان بيقول يلا نعمل
تبادل الاراضي برض كده فبيقول مش هنقدر
نخلص على حماس ونقضي عليهم بالبنادق دول
يطلع لهم مظاهرات ضدهم في خان يونس كده
لغايه ما يسقطو ده جوري ايل ده جنرال اه
ده جنرال جور ايلاند خلاص بيقول مش قادرين
احنا هو الحل بالنسبه له تحصل بقى حرب
اهليه يحصل اتطال داخلي حد يقوم بالمهمه
منم عن انت قلت اكثر من حاجه مهمه اولا
دان حالوتس اللي هو قائد اركان رئيس اركان
رئيس اركان قبل كده ا هو بيقول ان افضل
حاجه او افضل انتصار اسرائيل ممكن تحققه
انه تتخلص من نتنياهو اللي هو سبب مشاكلها
وبعتقد انهم خسروا الحرب لكن الاهم من
الكلام ده اللي احنا سمع سمعناه من اخرين
انه هو طرع على لسانه سيناريو الانقلاب
العسكري لانه احنا لما طرحنا الكلام ده في
الحلقه اللي فاتت بعض الناس يعني فوجئ ف
كلمه انقلاب عسكري باتت تتداول حتى على
هذا المستوى من المسؤولين يعني اه ما هو
الفكره انا كوزير دفاع بقابل الرئيس
المساد ليه تعال ما تقابل رئيس الم لسه
هسالك على دي اه انا قصدي دي مؤشرات ان في
اجواء غير طبيعيه كل واحد بيحاول يسبق
يحاول يحصن نفسه يمنع الانقلاب الثاني
يحاول يمهد للانقلاب بمعنى ان انا داخل
على الديوان رئيس الج رئيس الوزراء فبت فش
عشان انا كزير دفاع او رئيس اركان اه فده
مؤشر المؤشر اان التسريبات اللي ضدهم ان
لا انتوا فشله انتوا الجيش بتاعكم مش جاي
طب مدام قلنا كده بقى خلاص الموضوع اللي
انا كنت ماجله يعني في الحلقه في كلام
من
اعتقد يدعوه ت احرنوت انا لا اتذكر اسم
الجريده ولكن احد الجراد الاسرائيليه
الكبيره تحدثت عن توتر جديد بين رئيس بين
وزير الدفاع ونتنياهو بسبب اصرار نتنياهو
على منع رؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه الشباك
والموساد من اطلاع وزير الدفاع على تفاصيل
صفقه
الاسر ده صحيح الاول دقيق اه طبعا دقيق
بالفعل تم استدعاء الرئيس المساد على يد
وزير الدفاع وايضا رئيس الاستخبارات
الداخليه
لاطلاع وزير الدفاع
على مجريات التفاوض حول المحتجزين وال
الاسر فنتنياهو مجموعته بيقولوا لا ده مش
من صلاحيات وزير الدفاع وانا المشرف عليهم
بشكل مباشر على مساده على الشباك اه وان
هذا لا يجوز وغير مقبول واشتباك اشتباك من
حيث المبدا نفسه لماذا لكن الاخطر من
موضوع المبدا ان في جفوه وان في استمرار
للتصعيد بين معسكر نتنياهو ومعسكر جالانت
والعسكريين الذين
يساندونه محاولات للتشويه ان هذا هو السبب
في خسارتنا في عدم تحقيق الانجازات فت
بدوا الاتهامات بينهم وصل اللي هو تسريبات
وتاكيدا بانها يحاول ان يلتف حوالين رئيس
الوزراء تجاوز صلاحياته وزير الدفاع تجاوز
صلاحياته بمحاوله معرفه مسار المفاوضات
المحتجزين او الاسرى يعني من رؤساء
الاجهزه الامنيه وده بيتفق مع اللي احنا
قلناه قبل كده ان في جفوه حقيقيه وان في
صدام حقيقي و في ضب تحت الحزاب هو ايه
مشكله رئيس الوزراء مع اسم الحرب يعني
يعني
يعني دوقتي الحرب موجوده والمشاكل كتيره
قوي هل من اهم من هذه المشكلات يعني من
اولويات رئيس الوزراء هو تغيير اسم الحرب
والله ده عامل صدمه في اسرائيل بيقولوا
قواه العقليه تمام يعني انا دلوقتي راسمين
رسم كاريكاتيري لنتنياهو هو واقف قدام
جدار مكتوب عليه اسماء من سقطوا في هذه
الحرب رقم يعني 500 عسكري وضابط غير
المدنيين ف عمال يبص ويقول لا ده كده مش
كويس قوي احنا لازم نغير اسم
الح يعني ف طب بتفكر بتعمل ايه قال انا
بفضل بشيت في البدء اللي هو سفر التكوين
اسم سفر التكوين في في التوراه اول سفر من
اسفار التوراه طب يعني ايه السبب كنا احنا
بنختار اسم مفرد اللي هو ايه عمود السحاب
الجرف ص انا دلوقتي جبت السيوف دي فايه مش
ماشيه انا عايز اغير باسم ايه التكوين دي
كلمه مفرده وفي ناس تانيه قالوا الاسم
الاولاني ممكن يساوي ارقام الارقام دي
تساوي كذا يعني دخلنا في بعض الشعوزه ان
الارقام الابجديه تساوي قيمه رقميه المهم
ان في الاخر دخلنا في مساحه من الجدل
حوالين نغير ولا ما نغير انما انا تفسير
يعني ان هو ممكن يكون بيقول قول ان
ده زي خلق جديد وان زي ما سفر التكوين
بيقول ان الخلق ده تم في سته ايام وان
الرب بنفسه ما قدرش يخلق الامور العالم ده
الا في سته ايام فبالتالي يدوني فرصه انا
كمان انا بشر فممكن اقعد ست سنين مثلا هو
يعني الدلاله في
انه هو قبل كده اص هو قال حاجه مشابهه هو
قال هذه حرب تشبه حرب الاستقلال ايوه انا
بالنسبه لي ده كان مفهوم حرب الاستقلال
معناها انه كفاح كبير جدا على صعد مختلفه
ويحتاج الى سنين الان هو يريد تغيير اسم
الحرب بس باسمه مرتبط بالثقافه اليهوديه
حرب التكوين معناها زي ما ربنا خلق السماء
والارض يقدر يقول كن فيكون بس اختار سته
ايام فاصبروا معايا انا نتنياهو ممكن افوز
في هذه الحرب واخلق اوضاع جديده ولكن مش
في سته ايام ولا سته شهور في وقت اطول
كثير مش كده برض هو الخلاصه ص صحيح اه فجا
رئيس الاركان بيساله رئيس الوزراء بيسال
رئيس الاركان يقول له تقديرك موضوع غزه ده
يقعد قد ايه قال له على الاقل سنه فالتاني
انفرجت اساريره هو عايز يقعد سنه اه عايز
يقعد سنه يبقى رئيس وزراء لمده سنه حاجه
مش يعني مش بطاله لان ممكن يتنسي بقى
الفساد بتاعه الفشل
الامني هو باختصار شديد انت كنت قلت لي
قبل كده اكثر من مره انه بعض الاسرائيليين
بيشكك في انه صحه نتنياهو لا تسمح له
بالحكم ايوه هو ليه قصه طويله في مساله
الحاله الصحيه يعني بس لو بايجاز يعني ا
هو دخل سرا المستشفى عده مرات ومره منهم
تحت ستار عربه عربه تطهير المستشفى من
الحشرات شركه اه فهو شركه اللي هي الشركات
اللي بتنظف التخلص من الحشرات فالمهم ان
هو ا حاليا عنده منظم لضربات القلب وده
واحد من 200 شخص في اسرائيل عنده الحاله
ديت ا فبالتالي هو يعني
ا دايما المعارضين يقولوا لا انت صحيا مش
جاهز غير لا انت قضائيا قانونيا مش جاهز
انت ايضا صحيا مش جاهز امنيا اثبتت فشل
فمن ضمن الحاجات اللي بقت تتاخد عليه ان
هو صحيا ا مش جاهز
ا الراي العام برده الاسرائيلي كان تم
التعبير عنه في كاريكاتير ان في زوجات ال
اه افضل قوات الاحتياط زوجاتهم حالتهم
عامله ايه فجاب لوحه تلفزيون بيتكلم فيه
المتحدث العسكري اللي هو محام الشيطان ده
بيقول احنا اخترنا جدا من تحطيم حركه حماس
فالست قاعده على الكنبا وبتقول يعني اتمنى
ان ده يحصل قبل ما انا نفس الهار اه يعني
لو تلاحظ بس المشهد في الحكايه دي في كلب
الكلب ده بينبح على على متحدث باسم جيش
الاحتلال دي من الرسام مقصوده لان الكلاب
على عكس المعتاد ما بتهوهوش على الناس
1000 واحد اللي عد عليها طول النهار هي
ليها استيريو تيب كده ده يعدي وده معاييره
في حاجه غلط لازم اهجم عليه ويصر ف الرسام
بيقول ان الراجل ده في حاجه غلط حتى عبر
الشاشه الكذب بينضحك نفسه مستنفر قصاد
اللي طالع من الراجل ده فده كانت اشاره
كده عشان يهرب منحد من الرقابه العسكريه
لا هو تفسير حلو وبعدين انت ادتني معلومه
اضافيه انا ليه ب احيانا الكلب يمب عل انا
مش عارف ليه شايل شايل حاجه غلط بيتحرك
بشكل غلط هو في مشكله في الشخص يعني تاكد
ده صحيح هل عندنا حاجه لفت نظرك يا معالي
الدكتور في الاعلام الاسرائيلي خلال هذا
الاسبوع خلاف ما ذكرته يعني السيد حاولوا
اعاده تدوير نفس الافكار ده يدل على افلاس
يعني موضوع الترانسفير ده من ايام اتسل
ولحي منظمات اليونيه سنه 35 هنعمله طوعي
ولا قهري ولا
وده اللي بيتكلموا عليه من سنه 35 تكلموا
على
ا الترحيل لسينا ففي صحيفه معارف وصحيفه
ثانيه انجليزيه اسرائيليه قالت برض نفس
استاذ جغرافيا في جامعه بار ايلان الجامعه
اللي طلعت الارهاب بال قتل اج اج العمير
اللي قتل رابين رئيس الوزراء ب ايلان طالع
فيها استاذ جغرافيا يقول لا برده راحلهم
على سينا وده حل لطيف وفي هناك مياه في
شمال سينا وده امتداد للقطاع غزه الضيق
ومساحه هنا والمساحه هناك وبرده بيعيد
اختراع العجله ويصر على حلول احنا مصر
رفضناه وقلنا لهم مهما كانت النتائج
والغضب الشعبيه اللي طلعت مسنده فده يدل
ان هو لا لا يكل المخطط الاساسي مطروح لا
يزال في الدرج مستني اي فرصه ان هو ينفذه
انا لما بسمع الكلام ده بفتكر يعني اراء
بعض السياسه السياسه الاسرا الامريكان
اللي هم دعموا اسرائيل كثيرا لكن احيانا
في مذكراتهم ومنهم ترومان اللي هم
بيعتبروه طبعا هو اللي اعترف بدوله
اسرائيل وبيعتبر ان هو المعيار على مدى
دعم اسرائيل تدعمنا قدر ترومن ولا اقل
شويه ولا اكثر شويه انما هو في مذكراته
بيتكلم بملل ان الناس دول بيطلبوا مني ما
لا يطلبه احد ام عشان ما خرجش كتير برا
الموضوع هم ممكن يقولوا كده عن الامريكان
يطلبوا من الامريكان امور مش مقبوله لكن
انا مش عارف ايه الدلال اللي للاسرائيليين
على الدول الاخرى عشان يطلبوه يعني باماره
ايه اطلب من مصر مثلا فيفر صغير خد
لملايين دول فانا اصفي القضيه ديت الارض
دي من اهلها وخذوهم انتم عندكم ده معروف
صغير تعملوه لليهود اللي اللي بتم جميلها
وخلص باماره ايه اطلب من الدول العربيه
تعالوا شاركوا لي في اداره في اعاده
الاعمار اللي انا دمرته ادفعوا انتم يا
دول الخليج باماره ايه لو انا ما هجرت
الفلسطينيين اجيب الدول العربيه تحكم لي
هؤلاء الفلسطينيين وتبقى هي الشرطي باماره
ايه اطلب من مصر مثلا ان انا لا انا هحتل
فلادلفيا بس في نفس الوقت المجتمع الدولي
ما يعاملني على ان انا سلطه احتلال وعلي
واجبات تجاه ال القطاع او الارض التي
احتلها وفي نفس الوقت اطلب من المصريين
انتوا قموه بدور الشرطي ووجدو لي حل لسلحه
اللي هي بتجي لي لو انت مصره ان في اسلحه
بتيجي زي ما كان مبارك بيقول طب ما النفق
الاثنين وانتم بتقولوا احنا اعظم جهاز
مخابرات في العالم موجوده دلوقتي موجوده
فمعرفش الاسرائيليين عندهم اعتقد حلول هو
الحل انهاء الاحتلال اتنازل عن هو التعبير
الاسرائيلي التنازل نازل على 22% من ارض
فلسطين التاريخيه ن وكده تمام جدا اتعايش
انما حزب ملاده اللي هو راح بقم ز سنه 88
كان برنامجه السياسي لترحيل
الجماعي الحل عند اسرائيل ان العالم كله
يقعد مع بعضه ويحل مشاكل اسرائيل بالشكل
اللي يعني طب جنوب افريقيا كده كفايه بقى
انا شاكر جدا مع شكرا حضرك ش شكرا
لحضراتكم ونلقاكم على خير ان شاء الله في
حلقات المقبله باذن الله